[Music]
you know that feeling you get when
you've got these really
really good results and you're just
really excited to share them with the
world
and i think everyone's gonna be really
excited to see what results you have
and then you know that other feeling you
sometimes get with that one
when you get this sinking suspicion that
maybe those really good results are
just too good to be true so this
happened to me a few months ago
i lead the engineering team at ursa labs
we're one of the
leading developers behind the apache
aero project
so arrow as you may know is essentially
building
the foundation for the next generation
of data frames and bigger data analysis
and i maintain arrows our package so i
was meeting with
our studios leadership because our
studio has been a generous sponsor
of ursa labs from the beginning
so i'm in the call and i'm there
with hadley wickham and with jj alair
founder ceo of our studio tariff kawaf
is president
and i was talking about this this result
that i found recently which was
i've been benchmarking arrow csv reader
and found
that you know arrow has lots of great
things that it does in its library i'm
going to show you some of them in this
talk
but even if you just use arrow as a csv
reader and
use it to read a data frame into r and
then you could use any other r package
on that data frame afterwards you would
get a big benefit
and in fact even on this particular new
york city taxi data set
that i was testing out on i found that
arrow was two to three times faster than
data table's csv reader
at this point hardly cuts me off and
says yeah
i don't know that doesn't sound right
you know data table
that that group they have optimized
really everything
that you could optimize out of reading
reading data into r
and so you know maybe you could match
their performance
maybe you could get a little bit better
but you couldn't be that much better
because i've done everything you could
do
and tariff added yeah you probably
screwed up something in your
benchmarking code you know you probably
actually
didn't do all the work you thought you
did and i thought about it and it's like
wow that's actually a much more
logical simpler explanation for the
result that i found that i
screwed up something in my code but i
figured i'd go check it out
and you know get back to them and i you
know compared the objects that i had
the data frames read by both were the
same size 15 million rows
both really big in memory so it checked
out it turned out
aero csv reader was two to three times
faster than data tables here
so we'd achieved an incredible result it
was literally incredible
like this group of people here that know
a lot about the internals of r
literally did not believe that it was
this fast
so how are we able to do that so
what i want to talk about today is how
characteristics of the arrow project
and particularly the community around it
enable us to do things that
we might otherwise have thought would be
impossible to do in our
so a little history so arrow uh was
started in 2016.
uh a group of database developers
and dataframe library maintainers got
together and realized that they were all
trying to solve similar problems
and rather than saying you know this is
fine and we're just gonna
keep duplicating each other's work what
if we work together
and create a shared uh foundation for
our work and we would all benefit from
that
so arrow is fundamentally about three
things first is
it is a format there's a specification
for how
data is represented in memory it's
columnar
and it's designed to take advantage of
features of modern cpus and gpus and
other hardware
there's also a set of 12 libraries that
implement it in different languages
python and r use the c plus plus library
but there are many others in the in the
aero project and then third there's this
broader ecosystem of packages
around uh projects around arrow that use
error in some form whether it's as their
internal data model
data model or as it's just a means of
exchange between projects
so how does this how do these
characteristics of arrow lead us to get
such unbelievable
performance and be able to enable us to
do things that we didn't think were
possible
and are so in terms of modern hardware
aero is designed to take advantage of
many features of cpus that
exist now that didn't exist when r was
developed initially
so r was first released in 1995
of course computer technology has
progressed quite a bit since then
and there's things that we can do i can
do on my laptop now that
you know was not part of not something
that was a thing back then
so for example my c my laptop here has
got eight cores
that's cpus that you can run in parallel
you can get a host on
on aws with 96 course that's pretty good
but r is generally only using one of
those so we're leaving a lot of
performance on the table newer cpus also
can take advantage of what's called simd
single instruction multiple data my
laptop for example can take up to 256
bits at a time so that would be the size
of eight
integers in r other newer ones can do
512 bits so
you can feed a lot more data into the
cpu at a time
if your code is designed to take
advantage of that but are generally is
not
so it's like you have this super fast
sports car and
you just want to take it for a spin
around the track and see what you can do
with it
but for whatever reason you know
you have to keep it you have to keep it
under 25 miles an hour you know
drive keep your hands at 10 and 2 on the
handle on the steering wheel
no nothing too crazy and it's a really
missed opportunity
so what do you do about that so you
could
write some c or c plus code in your r
package to
do multi-threading to take advantage of
all those extra cores that you have
available
you could write code to do some d
optimizations
but that's that's really hard frankly
and you know the number the number of
people that know how to do that
well isn't that great probably
and there are people who do that and
are going to be writing our packages
even smaller
so here's where the large arrow
community comes in handy here
so the uh the aero project has had
you know since it was created in 2016
it's had a steady growth
of uh contributors to the project over
time
well over 500 by now and what this means
is all of these people are working
together
on this project that's uh and the
benefits are shared
so in order to have uh
smart multi-threading in the r package i
didn't have to write that
someone else who understands how to do
that much better than i would did that
i didn't have to write some d code
either there are other people people who
work
on hardware that's the actual cpus
themselves that know what those
options are they wrote that code and
they're all contributing in and they're
not contributing it in because they want
to make the r package faster
they're contributing because they are
using the c plus plus library
for some other project or they're using
python which uses the same c plus plus
library that the art package does
so we benefit from all these other
communities contributions
so so what does that look like so
to give an example of how this work
plays out in reality i want to talk
about
this example this demo that i gave last
year at our studio conference
i was introducing the arrow r package
and
and i was going through this example
with the data set where uh
you take uh about ten ten and a half
years of new york city taxi data's two
million two billion rows
and you could scan that and to get some
results on that on your laptop
so i did some kind of sample deplier
you know filtering and selecting and
grouping and aggregating
on this data set that i opened with the
arrow package where i pointed a
directory of these files
and then i could query it and i got a
result in four seconds
over two billion rows that was pretty
good we're really happy with that
um i did a talk uh this past summer
and i redid the result just on the
latest version of the code
and it was twice as fast and i hadn't
really done anything
in the r package to do that this is all
based on improvements in the underlying
c plus plus code
that all the rest of the community was
working on
right before i did this talk now i ran
the code again on the latest version
and it's another 25 faster again
i haven't i didn't do anything to make
that happen it's it's just based on the
the aero community and its work so
you know how there's other reasons other
ways that this ecosystem
plays out and has benefits for us in the
in the our community so
you know when you hear that a bunch of
database developers got together
and decided that there wasn't a good
standard for
for columnar data and they were going to
create their own standard to unify all
of these
it might bring this xkcd comic to mind
where the creating creation of standards
to solve the lack of standards
just you know mix more problems more
standards more competing standards
um and there certainly is that risk but
you know five years on from the
uh creation of arrow we can start to see
we can see now
how the the benefits of this approach
have played out
so just to give an example so
suppose i i've i've got data in spark
and i want to i want really quick access
to that in python and r
what you could do is that you could from
spark you could write
uh you know a special adapter for python
a special adapter for r
that understands uh you know for in the
rs case
it understands r's you know vector types
and
specific you know the bits in the in the
vectors that
make up a data frame you have to do the
same thing for for
python for numpy or or pandas um
and you know spark in its java code
would have to understand how to do this
i put another error in the arrow in the
chart there to connect the interchange
between python r that's obviously
something you'd want to do too
and it's another place where you'd need
someone on the other side of the
language barrier to
understand the internals of your format
so that's feasible
if this is all you care about but you
know in reality
the system is there's many more
languages and there's many more projects
and too many to fit on the slide
and as you can imagine if you try to
draw all of those lines to
you know connect the various adapters to
the different things it gets
crazy really quickly so so what do you
do
you're obviously not gonna do that
that's too much work um
and so you know what you want is to have
a ubiquitous standard that everyone can
write to and read from
and then you don't have to you don't
have to reimplement everything
every time um so
what and what you know prior to arrow
what you do
is probably just dump out a csv every
every language knows how to read a csv
every database knows how to read in a
csv um
but this is this comes with some costs
csvs can be expensive to
read and write because you have to
convert between a
string format on disk to the
you know the arrays of of bits that you
that are and the languages use in memory
to do work
and that conversion is costly and csv
also doesn't have rich support for types
you know you may have
time stamps and you don't have any way
of indicating that this is a time stamp
you have to guess whether it should be
just a regular string or a timestamp and
so there's lots of costs and
penalties that come from doing this but
csv is kind of you know lowest common
denominator and so
that's why it gets picked up but what
arrow is kind of a happier version of
that
where you are uh you have a standard
and it's columnar and it's binary so it
matches
very closely with how our julia or spark
or any of these
languages actually work with data in
memory
so the conversion is minimal and in some
cases
doesn't actually involve copying memory
because it where it does actually
line up as being the same shape so it's
very efficient
and from our perspective in the r
community what this means is once we
have
and now that we have an arrow our
package we have access to all of these
other
projects and databases and languages uh
very efficiently as long as they also
can write to arrow
and over the last five years we've seen
an increasing number of projects that
have picked up on arrow for this because
it's really efficient
so going back to spark for our example
there
early on in uh in arrow's life
we added support to in
pi spark the python spark library
to communicate with spark the database
switzerland and java
very efficiently using arrow and so you
know you'd get
you know 100 fold speed up
on certain operations whether it's with
user-defined functions or whether you're
just pulling a large amount of data into
your
your uh your python environment to do
further analysis on it
and that worked because java has an
error library
python has an error library and they
write the same format
the beauty of this is that once we
finally got the r package going
we could pick up and do the same thing
these are both references to
blog blog posts on the aero website so
we were able to take advantage of the
same thing
and uh because we can read and write
arrow
from r we didn't need to do any other
special
spark business in order to get those you
know 100x speedups
of pulling data to and from spark
and r so the error format is designed to
take advantage
of modern hardware and the power of the
large community of developers around the
aero project
really changed what we're able to do in
our and enable all sorts of new
workflows that
weren't really possible or feasible
before
so you know it's nice like i showed in
the beginning to to see
that um you know arrow makes
you know like reading csvs into r faster
and you know it's we like seeing that
but that's really not the goal you know
we're not just trying to
shave off a little bit of time from from
work work that you already can do now
we're trying to go beyond that we're
trying to enable new workflows so we're
either
cost prohibitive to do before or just
frankly not
not possible at all there's a lot
more coming in the next really in the
coming releases this year in 2021 really
excited to be able to tell you about
them when they come
but for now i wanted to just go back and
walk you through another example of
something you can do
today in the aero package that
is a little bit beyond what you would
normally do
in r but can really have some
some uh impossible seeming results let's
say
so um earlier i showed reading
a a data set of 125
files of new york city taxi data that
was in the parquet format
parquet is a file format that you can
read in
the arrow package it's a columnar very
efficient file format
often of course you don't have parquet
files yet and one of the reasons you
want to use arrow is to get your less
efficient csv data
into parquet so that you can read it
more quickly
so the error package has some facilities
for doing this
so here's an example i read i converted
some of those parquet files back to csv
i only did six months of it because
these are big and it takes a lot of
space but you can
just as you can point out a directory of
parquet files and say
open dataset you can do that with csvs
and you can do
same kinds of queries on them that you
did
you know i showed with the parquet
dataset you know selecting and filtering
grouping aggregating all these things
as you see you know the result here the
one i showed is a different query so
it's not apples to apples but you know
it took
seven and a half seconds to do this
query over this data
it's pretty good the fact i didn't have
to mess with
reading each of the files individually
and doing things with it that's good
but you know i think we can do better
so one of the things we want to do is we
could write the data set to a more
efficient format either par k as i
mentioned or feather which is the arrow
format it's literally the arrow format
on disk so
we can use similar types of deployer
style
syntax to do this i can say group by
this payment type column in the data set
that was one of the
columns that i filtered on before and
when i in this case when i'm writing a
data set when i say
group by what that means is i want you
to partition my data by that
and what that's going to do is it's
going to write out
separate files inside different
directories based on the value of that
variable so payment type in this data
set took on values 1 to 5.
so now i've got inside my feather taxi
directory i've got
five subdirectories one for each of the
values of
payment type that now have
different parquet files in it or feather
files excuse me
and what this means is when i do a query
again on this data set
i only and if and if i filter on payment
type i only have to look
at the files inside that directory that
correspond to the
value of payment type that i'm filtering
on i don't even have to read the other
files in to see if they match my filter
because i've kind of
pre-filtered it based on this
partitioning
so indeed if we do the same query that i
just did on the csvs
but i do it on the feather version of
the data set it's now
a hundred times faster than before exact
same query
just with a more efficient file format
and taking advantage of partitioning
in the dataset query so
this is great you know we're trying to
make things that have been
you know difficult or impossible
possible uh
trying to help you take full advantage
of the sports car that you've got
on your lap when you're uh when you're
working in r
um but you know i really i like to think
of what we have
is not just in the old sports core
sports car but it's it's a delorean
uh perhaps with a flux capacitor in it
and where we're going
we don't need roads we're going beyond
what you could
be doing on your laptop today even
so thank you very much
you